ja deswegen gab es sprachlos muss jeder
sagen
[Applaus]
Checkpunkt mit dem Tom mit dem Handy
Reaktionen zum Beispiel der minus Bär
schreibt ich hoffe so sehr dass Anna es
schafft wenn du das liest Anna ich
wünsche dir von Herzen dass alle beste
ich glaube fest an dich du kannst es
schaffen
[Gelächter]
super wie du das machst
ob sich seit dem ersten Film im Quartier
etwas geändert hat und ob die Menschen
vom Checkpunkt nun zum Beispiel mehr
Kontakt zu antworten oder Interessierten
haben oder Menschen sogar mehr spenden
oder so vorbei bringen wird sich das
entwickelt
[Musik]
ich bin selbst aus der Gegend und gingen
in den letzten Jahren sehr oft an der
Garage vorbei hatte immer ziemlich
Respekt vor dem Leuten dort und nun war
es sowas von spannend einen Einblick in
die Leben zu erhalten eine wirklich sehr
spannende und berühmte dokumen mehr
davon also Menschen aber eine neue
Perspektive Geschichte
[Gelächter]
das Projekt das tut weh das Projekt und
möglich geht es so dass man so stark ist
dass man nicht
das in Erfahrung hält wie soll es
als sie nach dem Unfall habe ich
Hauptsache
und allem
ja
Herausforderung
aber sie jetzt gleich kassiert aber noch
andere Hunde
entwickelt
die schönen Nachrichten
und ähm
finanzieren ganz bis maximal 700 Franken
okay
wie das mit dem Hund geht sind da
Bedingungen an die Hundehaltung geknüpft
meistens achte Tierheime ja auch darauf
wie das Umfeld des Hundes sein wird es
da vielleicht jemand im Hintergrund hat
Tom ein Zuhause
und klar so ist das Problem
so viel Alkohol trinken aber sehr jetzt
nie mit Monster Hund würde alles machen
schön ins Bettli und er wird wirklich
Verwandten auch und ich bekomme immer
wieder
Hund wo musst
und das Annemarie von tierferien
offerieren und auch medizinisch
begleiten oder falls mal
denn ich sehe aus Backup was du da 100
sagen
vielen Dank für deine weitere sehr
spannende authentische und emotional
sehr berührende Reportage mich würde
interessieren ob Sandy eine
Arbeitsstelle hat und falls nein ob sie
sich vorstellen könnte wieder einer
Arbeit nachzugehen also im Moment fange
ich keine Arbeit
[Musik]
Arbeitsprogramm schaffen
Standort gefunden das ist auch weiter
treffen die Standortfrage
drüber reden
[Musik]
die Betroffenen Dankbarkeit gegenüber
dem Steuerzahler der ihr da sein
finanziert
vielleicht also mit weniger hey aber das
gleiche so und also ich Vermehrung
und
[Musik]
dass sie mich so sehr sehr dankbar
Fabian
wie Teil 1 würde mich über einen dritten
Teil riesig freuen und feweit
macht
nicht alle müssen und können so
funktionieren wie einem dass die
Gesellschaft beziehungsweise seine
eigenen Vorstellungen vorgeben ich habe
diese zwei Tage sehr interessiert
geschaut bin sehr berühmt von den
Menschen habe auch geweint wie Tom
erzählt wir sind seine Gedanken und
Gefühlswelt ausschaut ich hoffe sehr
dass es mit der italienischen Hündin
Kamera und klappt auch der lieben Anna
wünsche ich dass sie einen Wunsch einen
Traum finden kann der gar nichts mit
Beruf zu tun haben muss einfach einer
der wenn es gelingt ihr mehr Freude im
Leben bereitet alles Gute und Liebe den
Damen Herren auch noch zulassen ganze
Checkpunkt
und mir persönliches spannender
wertvoller Übelkeit
verbessert optimiert vergrößert mich
einfach dankbar sein
[Musik]